dans ce magasin d'électroménager de
nombreux clients sont à la recherche du
meilleur compagnon en période de
canicule
le ventilateur pour la neige c'est une
première juillet-août ça va être
certainement un été très chaud donc je
j'anticipe maintenant mois de juin voilà
des desmarais s'équiper dès le mois de
juin
un réflexe inédit selon les vendeurs ses
allées étaient prises d'assaut le week
end dernier
résultat un chiffre d'affaires mensuel
réalisé en moins de deux heures le
samedi plus de plus de 20 millions de
chiffre d'affaires sur sur tout ce qui
est rafraîchisseur climatiseurs c'était
une bonne journée pour réapprovisionner
ses rayons à temps la direction a dû se
tourner vers d'autres enseignes du
groupe en france et jusqu'en nitec dans
cet autre magasin les clients se ruent
aussi sur les climatiseurs
une quête réalisé également sur internet
cette dernière semaine les ventes
explosent elles vraiment là ce matin
jusque sur la matinée on est à peu près
une cinquantaine de commandes
une cinquantaine de commandes en une
matinée donc soit 50 % du chiffre
d'affaires total d'un mois de juin
d'autres personnes sont contraintes de
travailler sans climatiseur ni
ventilateur aux bouteilles d'eau bandeau
ou zones d'ombré tous les moyens sont
bons
sur ce chantier quatre ouvriers
travaillent tout au long de la journée
avec des conditions climatiques
exceptionnelles
nous sommes avec eelv en vue covic le
chef de chantier dites-nous en quoi le
planning doit être modifiée dans ces
conditions là qui sont
exceptionnellement on prend plus plus
souvent de pause il faut savoir
s'écouter en fait on voit en ces
hydrates beaucoup apprendre
5-5 6 pts 5/6 pause pendant la journée
professionnels comme particuliers de
saône et loire vont devoir redoubler
d'imagination pour se protéger d'un pic
de chaleur prévue pour le milieu de la
semaine